>> Greg: AT A SYMPOSIUM,
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR HIRONO WAS
ASKED WHAT DEMOCRATS MUST DO TO
CONNECT WITH VOTERS.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DEMOCRATS HAVE A REALLY HARD
TIME IS CONNECTING TO PEOPLE'S
HEARTS INSTEAD OF HERE.
WE ARE REALLY GOOD AT SHOWING
ALL THE INFORMATION THE TOUCH
PEOPLE HERE BUT NOT HERE, AND
I'VE BEEN SAYING IT.
WE NEED TO SPEAK TO THE HEART,
NOT IN A MELEE DATED WAY --
MANIPULATIVE WAY BUT TO SPEAK TO
THE HEART SO THAT WE KNOW THEY
ARE ON THEIR SIDE.
>> Greg: THEN THEY SINGLED BY
OR WAIT A SECOND.
THE PROBLEM WITH DEMOCRATS IS
THAT THEY ARE TOO INTELLECTUAL
AS OPPOSED TO EMOTIONAL?
THIS FROM A PERSON WHO SLAMMED
ALL MEN IN ONE BURST OF RAGE.
>> IT'S THE MEN IN THIS COUNTRY,
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY TO THE
MEN IN THIS COUNTRY, JUST SHUT
UP AND STEP UP.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
YOU, BUT I DON'T SEE THAT
CONNECTING WITH ANYONE'S BRAIN,
UNLESS YOU MEAN HITTING SOMEONE
OVER THE HEAD WITH A MALLET.
THE REAL PROBLEM IS THE OPPOSITE
OF HER DIAGNOSIS, AND IT WAS
CAPTURED IN THE JUVENILE
OUTBURST FROM THE CAPITAL
HEARINGS.
ANGER FOCUSED AGAINST OTHERS FOR
BEING OTHERS.
IT'S WEAPONIZED IDENTITY.
I SUGGEST MORE MUTUAL
UNDERSTANDING, CONNECTING WITH
COMMON SENSE THAT WE ALL SHARE
AND SHARE IS THE KEY WORD THERE.
THE PROBLEM WITH DEMOCRATS AS I
SEE IT IS THE DESIRE TO PULL
APART RATHER THAN PULL TOGETHER.
FOR A LIBERAL, IT'S HARD TO EVEN
ADMIT PATRIOTISM IS A GOOD
THING.
IT IS SO OLD, CRUSTY, AND MEAN.
INSTEAD, LOOK BACKWARD WITH
SHAME AND DEFINE ALL PRESENT
RELATIONSHIPS AS OPPRESSIVE.
THE RESULT IS YOU SPLIT PEOPLE
INTO NEVADA DRIVEN INFECTIONS.
THE RESULT OF THAT, SENATOR WHO
DENIGRATES ALL MEN AS GUILTY
PARTIES.
THAT DOESN'T COME FROM THE HEART
OR BRAIN.
IT COMES FROM MAZIE HIRONO WHO
STILL OWES US DUDES A SERIOUS
APOLOGY.
ALTHOUGH IT WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
DANA, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HER
ANALYSIS?
THEY CONNECT TOO MUCH WITH THE
BRAIN AND THE NEED TO CONNECT
WITH HEARTS.
>> Dana: I THINK IT'S A
VARIATION ON THE DEPLORABLES
THEME BECAUSE WE CAN'T POSSIBLY
EXPECT PEOPLE IN AMERICA TO
UNDERSTAND HOW INTELLECTUALLY
SUPERIOR THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SUPPOSEDLY.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN BLAMED
FOR THIS IN THE PAST AS WELL.
TALK TOO MUCH ABOUT THE DEFICIT
AND DEBT AND YOU ARE TOO MUCH
ABOUT PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
FRANKLY IT WAS SOMETHING THAT
WAS SAID ABOUT GEORGE H.W. BUSH.
HOW DID BILL CLINTON
DIFFERENTIATE HIMSELF?
WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> Greg: I FEEL YOUR PAIN.
>> Dana: I FEEL YOUR PAIN.
>> Greg: HE TRIED TO TOUCH
OTHER THINGS AS WELL.
BUT WE WON'T GET INTO THAT.
>> Dana: HILLARY CLINTON HAS
THE PROBLEM THAT'S THE REVERSE.
DONALD TRUMP IS ABLE TO CONNECT
WITH PEOPLE EMOTIONALLY AND THEY
ARE SO FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THEY
CAN GET THE FACTS OUT.
THE FACTS, THE FACTS, THE FACTS.
IT WILL BE FUN TO SEE THIS 2020
CLASS OF DEMOCRATS.
I THINK WE ARE DOWN FROM 40 2:30
EIGHT.
>> Greg: WE LOST AVENATTI.
>> Dana: AND WE LOST DEVAL
PATRICK TODAY.
>> Greg: SANDRA, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THIS?
>> Sandra: WE WELCOME A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS ON "AMERICA'S
NEWSROOM."
QUITE A FEW OF THEM COME ON WITH
US.
I ASKED THEM, AS I ASKED
REPUBLICANS, WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE
BECAUSE PART OF THE PROBLEM FOR
DEMOCRATS IS THEY ARE NOT SAYING
WHAT THEY STAND FOR.
IF YOU WERE TO TRANSLATE HER
SAYING WE SHOVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION OUT THERE, WE PUT A
LOT OF TALKING POINTS OUT THERE.
PART OF THE RESIST MOVEMENT IS
TO SAY THINGS AND NOT ACT.
TO DANA'S POINT, REPUBLICANS
ABOUT A HARD TIME WITH THAT
HISTORICALLY AS WELL, TALKING
ABOUT TAX CUTS OF THE DEFICIT.
WHAT IS IT GOING TO MEAN AT THE
END OF THE DAY FOR YOUR FAMILY?
YOU HAVE TO APPEAL TO THEIR
HEARTS.
FOR DEMOCRATS, IT'S GOING TO
HAVE TO TAKE ACTION BECAUSE
THERE IS A WHOLE LOT OF TALK
RIGHT NOW.
>> Greg: I DON'T BUY IT.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY USE THEIR
BRAINS TOO MUCH.
IT'S LIKE THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
DUE PROCESS BIOLOGY, THE
NECESSITY OF FREE MARKETS OR
ECONOMICS, PATRIOTISM OR
COMMUNITY.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE NOT
THINKING AT ALL.
>> Jesse: PERMISSION TO MAKE
AN ANALOGY, GREG.
>> Greg: I WOULD LOVE THAT.
>> Jesse: SHE MISDIAGNOSED IT.
IT WOULD BE LIKE DONALD TRUMP
SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT, I AM TOO
POLITE.
I AM TOO POLITICALLY CORRECT.
I'M TRYING TO FORCE TOO MUCH
CONSENSUS.
I'M GOING TO BE MORE BRASH, AND
I'M GOING TO HIT IMMIGRATION
HARDER.
I HAVEN'T DONE THAT ENOUGH.
FIRST OF ALL, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS ALWAYS PUT
EMOTIONS OVER FACTS.
LOOK AT THE CAPITAL HEARINGS.
ALL THE FACTS WERE ON HIS SIDE,
THEY WANTED YOU TO BELIEVE THIS
WOMAN WHO HAD NO FACTS.
LOOK AT THE PARKLAND SCHOOL
SHOOTING.
EVERYTHING WAS SAYING IT'S A
FAILURE OF THE FBI, STATE,
LOCAL, POLICE.
THE DEMOCRATS WANTED YOU TO HATE
IN YOUR HEARTS THE NRA OR ANY
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM THAT THE
DEMOCRATS PUT FORTH.
THEY DON'T CARE MUCH IT COSTS.
THEY DON'T EVEN CARE IF IT
REALLY WORKS THAT WELL.
THEY JUST WANT TO SHOW VOTERS
THAT THEY ARE COMPASSIONATE AND
THAT THEY CARE ABOUT YOU.
I THINK HER REAL ISSUE WAS SHE'S
NOT CONNECTING WITH THE
WORKING-CLASS VOTERS OF THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY ARE
FIXATED, THE DEMOCRATS, WITH
GLOBAL WARMING.
IDENTITY POLITICS.
YOUNG PEOPLE IN WEST VIRGINIA OR
THE RUST BELT SAYING WHAT ABOUT
ME AND MY FAMILY?
I AM AN AMERICAN.
STAND UP FOR ME.
>> Greg: WHAT IF, JUAN, A MALE
SENATOR SAID WOMEN, JUST SHUT
UP.
>> Juan: OBVIOUSLY THAT'S NOT
WHERE WE ARE IN AMERICAN CULTURE
AT THE MOMENT, GIVEN WHAT'S
GOING ON.
BUT TO ME, THE IRONY IS SHE'S
RIGHT.
DEMOCRATS I THINK HAVE TO LEARN
HOW TO SPEAK FROM THE HEART,
ESPECIALLY IN AN ERA WHEN YOU
ARE GOING UP AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHO MAKES HIS
APPEALS BASED ON FEAR,
GRIEVANCE, ANGER, WHITE
IDENTITY.
>> Greg: HE NEVER MENTIONS
WHITE IDENTITY.
>> Juan: YOU TALKED A MOMENT
AGO ABOUT PATRIOTISM.
HE TALKS ABOUT NATIONALISM,
GREG.
HE IS MAKING AN APPEAL THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE FEAR IS --
>> Greg: ITS PATRIOTISM.
>> Juan: LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
THE KIND OF VERY MUCH WHITE
NATIONALIST GROUPS THAT IDENTIFY
AND FOLLOW PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Greg: IT'S A FAULTY LOGIC.
YOU ALSO HAVE LEFT WING COMMIE
PINKOS THAT WOULD LOVE TO BE A
DEMOCRAT.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING --
>> Juan: I AM TALKING!
>> Greg: YOU NEVER STOP
TALKING.
>> Juan: YOU WERE TALKING.
YOU HAD A WHOLE MONOLOGUE.
>> Jesse: DON'T GO AFTER THE
MONOLOGUE.
DON'T YOU DARE.
>> Juan: HERE'S THE POINT.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT RIGHT NOW,
YOU HAVE TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT,
WE CAN TALK ABOUT HEALTH CARE.
SANDRA, THAT WAS THE MESSAGE,
AND EFFECTIVE MESSAGE DURING THE
MIDTERMS.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT HEALTH CARE
BUT THEN THE REPUBLICANS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP COME BACK AND
SAY NO, THAT'S SOCIALISM.
WE ARE TAKING IT APART.
YOU HAVE TO SAY TO PEOPLE WHAT
ABOUT --
AND THEN YOU HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION, BUT UNTIL YOU SAY
SHE WAS A CHILD DENIED
TREATMENT, UNLESS YOU CAN SHOW
THAT CHILD, DOESN'T HAVE
THE SAME POWER AS TRUMP MAKING A
WILD EYED ARGUMENT AND APPEALING
TO FEAR AND GRIEVANCE AND ANGER.
>> Greg: LET'S DISPATCH THIS
FALLACY ALTOGETHER.
IF REPUBLICANS LIKE ORANGES,
IT'S BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE